Quinnipiac poll is out Trump is
absolutely destroying this primary right
now and I know it's early and we've just
got these new candidates into the race
even within the last week we've seen the
entrance of Tim Scott Ron DeSantis and
it would seem Mike Pence but it is not
even close so Quinnipiac which is a
fairly well respected polling outlet
they say that in May Trump is at 56
percent the santis is at 25 none of the
other candidates are even close
that means that Trump is up 31 points
over DeSantis and that's from the
Quinnipiac poll you've seen this
reflected in other polls with even wider
margins sometimes now the reason that
number matters is that it's going in the
right direction for Trump in March Trump
was only up 14 points on DeSantis it was
47-33 back in February Trump was only up
six points on DeSantis so now maybe that
DeSantis is officially in the race maybe
this will give him a big move to be able
to weaken Trump and then that'll benefit
all of the other candidates but as of
right now this is Far and Away Trump's
race to lose